according to members of her family her
mother and her brother who have spoken
to media outside of iran they say that
masa was arrested on september 13th when
she was leaving a subway station in the
capital tehran her brother was with her
at the time she was detained by the
morality police she was then ushered
into a van and transported to a police
station and then at that police station
according to the officials here who have
since released cctv footage she suddenly
collapsed the police say they believe
she had pre-existing conditions and that
was the cause of the heart attack her
family have a different version of
events they say she had no pre-existing
health issues she was a healthy 22 year
old woman who was taken and she never
left that police station she was
transported to a hospital where she was
in a coma for a few days and then she
was taken off life support and
pronounced dead her family has laid her
body to rest in her hometown on saturday
morning and the entire country is
demanding an investigation into what
actually happened we've heard not only
from her family demanding answers from
officials we've heard from
the interior ministry who has launched
an investigation into determining the
cause of death we've also heard from
former high-ranking
officials inside iran including former
president
hatami as well as the
former foreign minister mohammad javad
zarif who have all expressed their
sorrow and deep condolences to the
family for the events that took place
the main issue here is not just what
happened to her the issue is that the
officials need to be responsible for the
well-being of people they have in
custody and that is something that is at
the heart of this issue at the moment